good morning believe nation today's
message is do your thing over to you
Luigi Kalani did it hurt you that the
especially on press and also the your
colleagues that did get along with you
very well this is part of my success
because I did my work in spite of them
they fought me like mad and I told them
if come on guys I do my thing and you
will see where I am where I'm going so
anything I love this because I think do
your thing to me it speaks to like you
know being who you are and bringing
yourself to to everything you're doing
it's like putting your own personal
signature on something when you're doing
your thing you're doing it your way be
used so much yeah yeah I have a couple
thoughts on this I think one too many
people worry about other people too much
this is a general rule I think as an
entrepreneur a lot of people are trying
to run a business based on what their
friends are thinking or their family's
thinking or maybe they want it they
don't start being entrepreneur because
their family holds the back and it's are
you living your life or someone else's
version of you
and at some point you gotta decide hey
this is my life I'm gonna do what I want
to do and I can't just keep living there
differently Stratus because you're never
gonna you never going to be happy you
never going to really be happy never
going to accomplish anything great if
you're not being you you just being
somebody else's version of you I think
the hardest scenario was the
parent-child relationship but your
parents want you to do something you
don't want to do it and the story I keep
thinking about is akio morita
started Soni his family was I think I
want to say 11 generations of sake
Brewers I might be a little off with the
number boy I want to say 11 and he was
expected to take over the business being
the eldest son in the math and Japanese
culture very traditional he was expected
to take over you got it this is not just
like a one generation thing it's is our
family legacy in history and he said no
I want to do it and he started
eventually Sony and Sony's become this
insane company but having the guts to be
able to do that and want to live your
life instead of what your parents want
you to do or anybody else I think the
other component that I would go on for
this is not looking too much about what
the competitors are up to I think too
many entrepreneurs compare themselves to
the competition and you're so worried
what other people are doing that you
don't do anything innovative or unique
right you're not gonna have a success
just by trying to copy somebody else you
can model success and then apply it to
your business and then use that to be
the best version of yourself but you at
some point need to innovate and do
something different and not just worry
about other people so when people rip
off my youtube videos or try to do their
own top 10 or their own morning series
people write to me and say hey man you
know this guy is trying to copy I don't
care like you can't out Evan Evan write
like can't do it and so I would rather
spend my time going more all-in on me
than worrying about what this other guy
is trying to do
topping me right and so the more you do
that the less you care what other people
the more likely you're going to be
successful
I do these random test those because
when they're long yeah I noticed it's
you know it's hard this it's easy to say
don't care what other people think it's
hard to execute right this is think
there's something in human beings where
you care you want to pool with other
people right you dress up when you go
out right why is that you want to prove
with other people so recently I was
walking to Toronto then sauce and I have
a dance mix on in my ears right now walk
to mostly side streets nobody's on kick
a man hitting the beat and then as soon
as I get closer to TDS it's on a Main
Street and there's people there and then
as soon as I see them I think my
instinct is people here and I think the
thing there is most people just do that
instinctively and don't recognize that
that's a limiting behavior like why do I
care about what these people here on
this street corner are seeing right and
so I then made the conscious effort to
then bring it up again right rock out
all right so good like I'm killing it
out there in the corner right I like it
I'm not getting everybody's face I'm not
trying to be offensive or you know
invade anybody's privacy but it's a
purposeful exercise and stretching my
comfort zone so I'm able to do it more
easy to the next time and continue to
expand what I am and am not comfortable
with even doing videos in public like
we're
tell right now people walking by I used
to be afraid of doing anything even
close to this people staring at us and
that we go just a couple seconds ago
well we kept going yeah it's like I
don't care anymore right because you've
done it and so practice when you feel
like you are not being yourself and
you're being judged and you can
recognize that and not just rely on
their subconscious behavior to shrink
back in if you can recognize that you're
shrinking in then try to force yourself
to come back to being you and the more
you can do that the more you'll stretch
your comfort zone and the more success
ultimately I believe that you will have
I love it I love your story about dances
on the street I dance my car all the
time and people stare at me in traffic
and I've danced in the car rock it out
this thing in the top of my lungs I
don't care but I love that as a personal
exercise to stretch yourself I love that
it's awesome so the question of the day
today is what are you gonna do to
stretch yourself what exercise you gonna
do to be more you I love it
leave in the comments below will join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events for so
when espresso give me go